do you notice anything different about
me today like the attitude is actually
kind of giving me some you heard the man
changing okay I'm working on my oh yeah
[Music]
hi my name is Andrea my name is David
and today we're eating like John Legend
you know good three four postmates
sorters I'm expecting like maybe a crab
omelet with like some gold flakes on it
or something like that what am i
delivering should have a red carpet
attached to it all for sure so that we
need to add that to the list
I'm a been a John Legend fan since his
UPenn days oh I'm deep in the catalogue
John Legend is my boy definitely a big
John Legend fan a lot of his music is
someone who loves to sing myself karaoke
time off a show pull out of ordinary
people every now and you don't say Sally
karaoke song you got salad you got to
you ready to do this yeah let's do it
let's eat some food let's eat
so first meal of the day my man got me a
classic cheeseburger John I've messed
with you I like cheeseburgers everybody
gives McDonald's a bad rap but like
these are classic I'm hungry my
breakfast was white this morning let's
do this alright so we're gonna get
started with the first one
I'm a fan of McDonald's cheeseburgers I
like their classic they've been around
for a long time it's similar to his
music I feel like it's a timeless staple
I'm a fan of McDonald's breakfast if
anything but that's usually after like a
long night or something anyway so the
cheeseburger from McDonald's was not
gonna be my go-to I crushed that burger
the burger was amazing I love it if I
can call this burger a John Legend song
I would probably call it ordinary people
cuz it's older but it's a classic and
you can't go wrong with a cheeseburger
and I just I feel more soulful already
do I look more soulful Sean
he's a derp it got me to find out so
much about this man that I do not like
now the fact that he was so pleased with
this burger I don't know why it's making
me so angry but it's not okay with that
John you're tripping hard to get rid of
that I'm gonna eat that anywhere but uh
we'll see what we get for lunch but
lunch we got fun it's definitely a
significant improvement from the DL and
Donald since we got delusional bean
sprout with bang going on even though
the herbs and vegetables and of course
the super safe we're gonna go ahead
before him and get started
it was pretty fine I don't know where
they got this one feeling a bit more
like John it's wrong like I'm made of
money it was a good like mid point for
the day you know what I'm saying it
didn't leave me too full you know I felt
like I could still go write a few more
hits you know I'm saying I felt like I
could go grab Luna you know I'm saying
take her to rich baby daycare it wasn't
for me there are rules that he broke in
his order like you don't go to a full
restaurant in order like chicken broth
like that doesn't make sense with the
Asian soups and the broth so you need a
red meat cuz it's heavy you got to get
the juices in there I felt like it was
like boneless chicken breast in like
noodles and noodles water this is very
forgettable it's a very forgettable
lunch how would you rate this from a
scale of one being John Legend's
collaboration on with the roots that
nobody knows about
to ten being all of me is like number
one song ever I would definitely rate it
like a three and a half it's almost a
bow out of ten
that's why don't you [ __ ] cuz it's just
a lot of puns all day it was crazy how
somebody who
excuse my language to McDonald's so
tough it's so critical of the father
right now my boy a nickel oh yeah you
know I gotta say [ __ ] you know me
fairly well it do you notice anything
different about me today do I give you
any type of I have anything different
than you - yeah
like the attitudes actually kind of
giving me you heard the man
I'm changing if ordinary people is a
cheeseburger the fur was like when he
was doing the Rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer John Legend cover - like right
it's one of those like other people have
done it better on seated other people do
orders better than John Legend but he
did it and it was cool but like the
Christmas albums like there's no there's
no Mariah though so you're back with the
next meal we got this
corn bread topped pop pie doesn't look
to be too amazing strangely enough when
I grab a pop on it was a big-ass piece
of cornbread on top of it
that was a surprise it was a pleasant
one that was it was a pleasant one
it looks good don't hang a light I'm not
like a potpie person but it does look
nice and like crispy you can see the
flakiness of it you know John and I
thought your taste would be a little
more sophisticated than this who orders
Popeye from any type of delivery peg you
feel me we really agreed during this
whole confessional time but that's one
thing I think we can agree upon kind of
live when I order a pot pot that's a
healthy Python is not one of them stingy
once we got up
peas carrots and all that good stuff
cause living like John Lydon all this
would taste better like if I could eat
this papaya while looking at a few
Grammys probably a lot more delicious I
was mad at the foot again because it
took some of my stomach capacity because
I would have loved to smash this pot pie
I'm a warm it up later though well I'm a
warm yeah I didn't pay for it but I'm a
pretend I did eat like John Legend for
Danny oh yeah at least it's gonna be
lunch on Friday for sure I'm not doing
that add that in and that's that on that
waiting for this meal all day we got the
wings the wings generally generally five
I prayed me some more it's very white
he's so skinny we bout to jump in you
got to go all the way in I was excited
for the hot way yeah we got them a
little later in the day so I had to warm
them up and from like the microwave the
wings are probably just see me dancing
in the kitchen because I was excited cuz
I already told y'all the [ __ ] took up a
lot of my room space I have my wings
ready the plate was there but I didn't
see no blue cheese and I just feel like
we need to have a conversation like I
have a forum here and I feel like we
need to talk about this ranch business
is your platform I don't know who told
you that ranch belongs always all the
variants commercial I've seen had cows
and like vegetables on it so I don't
know who thought that was a good
conversion but your boy
if I had to turn the Hooters order into
a John Legend song right I think this
one will probably be like all of me
because I was so excited for these wings
like all of me wanted to eat all the
wings
we've been John Legend and all day you
know I'm feeling really so I mean at a
piano all day we're gonna oh yeah
alright so if we're gonna rank the food
for me I would say number one it's
probably gonna be the potpie cuz I did
not see that coming
potpie was almost like the techno remix
of all of me when they started playing
it in the club's electronic like that
but out in this capacity I could I could
dig with it so I will put that number
one number two ordinary people a classic
American cheeseburger I felt like it was
real grounded he didn't change on nobody
I'll take these John this is a good
first start he's still the same person
that we knew from Chicago that I was
playing the piano and I felt I thought
at home when I ate that I felt my
childhood I heard all of his first album
then we gonna do the hooters wings
because he knows hooters wings that's
like the UM the song that had with andre
3000 green light you know it's a green
I'm always ready for some wings and then
yeah we talked about that man our vows
to rank these you know saying I think
the top would for sure be the fuch enjoy
some delicious for the broth was amazing
he ate like John Legend for one meal and
turned extra bougie I don't know what
his issue is you know after the FIR I
would definitely say to Popeye it's
surprising me I just got a little bit
sweet but it wasn't Cakes week you know
but a wedding too bland
it was quite moist quite moist as if it
is still kinda like ta fingers duct tape
there you feeling me when the top part
not the bottom when that top a little
part of that the cornbread stick to your
fingers me they go like they go like
that I would say the wings of course is
gonna be next um saying whose wings
can't go to wrong with those simple
pleasurable comfort food you know and
last would definitely be the McDonald's
cheeseburger I wish to never eat one of
those again it was salad oh so yeah I'll
definitely do this again
thank you John Legend
just hit it just send us a DM Jon Lester
pull up don't worry about it we'll make
it a lot going on we'll take care of
everything will come through we'll bring
some food I know what you like now so
I'll just bring like 30 of them Wang's
we could chill we go right now
yeah I'm ready to go right now - I'm
trying to look some more down for you
Charlie you gonna get pickup wings on
the way we can do that I'm not picky
[Music]